Stateville Correctional Facility outside
of Chicago home to some of Allah noise
deadliest men of the 1,500 inmates
nearly 60% are in for murder another 20%
are serving time for rape and other
violent crimes almost everyone here is
doing 20 years minimum the first look
most of the prisoners have of Stateville
is the reception and classification
center just beyond the prison walls most
of these men are not menacing enough to
be put in Stateville they will be sent
to other prisons in Illinois but all
have the potential to lash out so as
inmates enter it's crucial to the
officers safety to check closely for
contraband and weapon right leg up one
inmate recently tried to smuggle in a
razor in a Bible must be quiet you're
gonna be interviewed by multiple people
today at the RNC as it's called
prisoners are screened and evaluated for
several days on the basis of their crime
sentence aggression level and mental
health gonna get a half sheet they're
gonna mark off everything you've done
then you've got to turn it in to us so
we can get you to the cell
many of the worst of the worst will wind
up in a cell just across the yard at
Stateville built in 1925 Stateville was
once one of the most notorious prisons
in Illinois even in all of America
stabbings rapes and murders happened all
the time since the inmates had the run
of the place in 1990 when I arrived here
the prison was wide open as they say I
was thought Stateville had a no
ambulance a scientist Stateville not
realizing every time I came here there
was a staff being taken out all inmates
being taken out in the ambulance
nearly half of the buildings have been
closed down or condemned the rest are
hugely overcrowded
officers armed with shotguns and rifles
patrol these buildings constantly on
towers outside and from catwalks and
sniper positions within they are there
to maintain order and they'll use their
weapons if they have to it's been a good
winter so far nobody's fired their
weapon in a month